prix les vioques bonjour maurizio dans
bonjour aux auditeurs de martinique 1ère
vous êtes connu pour être l'actuel
président du medef martinique le mandat
qui va s'achever bientôt mais surtout
d'être en lice pour la présidence de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de la
martinique et la liste que vous menez
philippe giauque s'intitule entreprendre
ensemble en martinique êtes seul en
cause commenté
comme expliqué philippe jacq cette
absence d'adversité non je crois qu'il
faut simplement prendre conscience que
les intros bonne avance et necker ont
pensé qu'il était plus utile de parler
d'une seule voix ils se sont tous
regroupés
donc nous avons une liste qui regroupe
l'ensemble des organisations patronales
de la martinique et donc il n'y avait
pas lieu de se disperser
puisque nous avons des combats
importants qui nous attendent notamment
en matière fiscale la lodeom qui se
termine en décembre 2017
il faudra que nous travaillons tous
ensemble et que nous soyons force de
proposition auprès de leurs pagnes a eu
lieu avant la discussion est dû avant en
effet la discussion est dû avant les
campagnes vif
non ça s'est passé plutôt plutôt
simplement plutôt facilement nous avions
tous conscience de la nécessité d'avoir
la voix une liste unique pour s'exprimer
et être plus audible parce que lorsqu'on
regarde comment ça se passe a notamment
en guadeloupe c'est pas forcément une
belle chose cette campagne dans l'île
soeur alors attaques violentes parfois
personnel s'est dégradée ça prend une
mauvaise image du patronat mais ce n'est
pas l'image du patronat martiniquais
vous aurez noté que nous sommes avant
tiéné que beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
ouvert et que les différences en fait
sont pas si importantes entre les
organisations patronales
qu'il s'agisse du medef où la cgpme nous
avons une vision de développement
économique et ce qui est au coeur de nos
préoccupations c'est le développement
économique et l'emploi que sous tend ce
développement économique d'or c'était
très facile pour philippe giauque de
d'avoir un discours fédérateur medef
cgpme sans compter sans oublier plutôt
les très petites entreprises
en effet nous avons dans un premier
temps en discuter avec la fcpe medef tpe
et la cgpme nous a rejoints dans cette
dans cette dynamique unitaire dans
l'intérêt de l'entreprise alors manuel
beaudoin le sortant qui ne se représente
pas rappelle à qui veut l'entendre que
son équipe a assuré une mandature de
transition une équipe qui a géré la fin
de la gestion des ports et aéroports de
martinique donc la fête de rentrée
d'argent considérables pour la structure
l'état qui baisse des dotations en tout
cas qui demande aux chambres de commerce
de france de baisser leur train de vie
il va falloir trouver des recettes sylla
le prouve le principal enjeu pour vous
mais très clairement nous avons avec la
la fin des concessions portuaires est
aux portes hier la chambre de commerce a
vu diminuer de façon drastique et
sensible son budget aujourd'hui on est
sur un budget de l'eau devait 9 à 25
millions d'euros
et ça oblige la chambre de commerce à
revenir sur ses fondamentaux que sont
l'accompagnement des entreprises et la
formation
ce sont des sujets sur lesquels je pense
qu'il y a matière à développer
madgy rady le dos certes certes mais
nous avons un savoir-faire il ya matière
à développer des formations et donc des
recettes liées à ses activités et sur la
partie de l'accompagnement entreprise je
crois qu'il ya aussi des choses des
choses intéressantes à faire des
services que les entreprises sont prêts
à payer dès lors que ces services sont
de qualité sont pertinents et les points
dans leur demande donc il faut que
l'offre de services de la chambre de
commerce soit adaptée aux attentes de
ses ressortissants il ya technopole de
la cacem et la pépinière de cap nord à
plus les privés va falloir que je sorte
le pistolet d'ygrande la concurrence il
va falloir être comme véritable goleador
dans les surfaces un peu comme
berrichonne nolan roux à saint-etienne
n'ont même pas du tout on n'est pas on
n'est pas dans un conflit est dans une
compétition aussi acharné nous avons des
champs de compétences qui nous sont
reconnus par la pala par les textes et
nous avons un sujet qui peut permettre
de
à la chambre développer des recettes qui
la gestion du registre du commerce c'est
un combat que manuel beaudoin a mené
avec les autres présidents de chambre de
commerce outre-mer c'est un combat que
nous allons poursuivre parce que ça peut
être l'occasion pour la chambre d'avoir
des ressources supplémentaires
nous avons le champ de compétences qui
permet qui doit permettre à l'équipe à
l'équipe motivée qui m'accompagne et
opérationnelles dont la compétence est
reconnue de développer des recettes le
maintien financier de des ressources
financières de la cci ce sera le
principal enjeu de votre mandature nous
sommes d'accord là dessus très
clairement il ya une mandature
transition qui était la première où les
concessions portuaires et aux produits
elle disparaissait et là nous aurons
vrai enjeu une cci a reformaté pour
répondre aux limitations budgétaires qui
nous soit imposée vous venez avec votre
équipe il y aurait également le
personnel de la cci pour garantir
l'indépendance de la structure dans un
pays où le moindre soutien le moindre
sourire fait par exemple un politique
quel que soit son bord peut être
interprété de telle ou telle façon
le président de la cci doit se situer
comment par rapport à toutes ses forces
au sein du pays non mais le président de
la cci sera en contact avec les élus les
élus nationaux les élus locaux
mais par définition il ne fait pas de
politique il ne fait pas de politique
mais comme je vous l'aï dit nous sommes
dans un pays où un sourire oui mais
voilà ça peut prêter à confusion
alors j'espère j'espère simplement que
et nos élus et nos compatriotes
dépasseront ses sourires et comprendront
que nous travaillons tous à nos places
respectives dans l'intérêt de la
martinique
c'est ça le vrai sujet nous travaillons
dans l'intérêt de la martinique et des
martiniquais gars que vous prendrez vos
fonctions dans quelques semaines
philippe jacq
qu'est ce que vous ferez tout d'abord à
la cci un état des lieux
une rencontre avec l'ensemble du
personnel pour connaître leurs attentes
save our house en sont les savoir
comment on peut engager cette nouvelle
mandature avec les objectifs que nous
sommes fixés qui sont ceux qui ont
besoin de craindre pour son avenir
non je crois que l'air une centaine de
salariés à peu près tout est mêlé
les efforts ont déjà été faits la
restructuration a déjà été largement
engagée par l'équipe actuelle
l'adaptation des effectifs aux recettes
et tant qu'on est nous avons un grand
chantier que manuel barroso a mené qui
permettra de stabiliser le
fonctionnement de la chambre qui est le
pôle consulaire de formation
donc je crois que le personnel n'a pas
n'a pas à s'inquiéter outre mesure de
cette baisse continue des recettes que
je rentrais leur avantage qu'on ait
d'autres quand même dans un univers
procurant scié par exemple en termes de
services offerts aux entreprises mais je
crois que c'est déjà fait le personnel a
changé passer d'une logique d'usagé est
logique de clients et ça c'est une
c'est une évolution qui a déjà eu lieu
donc nous sommes simplement dans le
prolongement de cette discussion et de
cette dynamique
ces dynamiques de service et le service
payant et de services gratuits pour
certains à l'attention des
ressortissants de la chambre alors dans
votre programme un philippe choc le
volant légalement de faire en sorte que
la cci apporte son apporte sa pierre à
l'édifice en ce qui concerne le
rayonnement touristique
oui on ne peut pas imaginer développe en
avant et unique sans la composante
tourisme et donc à côté du organisme qui
existe comme le comité martiniquais du
tourisme nous avons l'ambition de porter
notre pierre à cette a7 à ce
développement touristique avec des
sujets qui sont déjà avancées comme la
stabilisation de certains de certains
commerces comme la digitalisation des
acteurs du secteur du tourisme des sites
internet qui doivent être multi langues
approuvée par eric le numérique sera un
autre cheval de bataille c'est un enjeu
fondamental cette prochaine mandature le
monde en parle oui mais c'est vraiment
l'enjeu il faut que les services soient
soient numériques est accessible à
distance il faut que les formations soit
digitalisées je prends l'exemple des
petites entreprises qui ont du mal à
dégager une journée aux deux proches
collaborateurs en formation on peut
imaginer des formations on doit
concevoir des formations non pas en
présentiel mais en e-learning avec la
possibilité pour le collaborateur de se
former une heure quand une baisse
d'activité plutôt que d'être là
attendre le client dernière question
henri salles au moins à la chambre des
métiers de l'artisanat a été élu alors
que l'abstention c'était quand même 95%
le challenge personnel de philippe jacq
ce qui est beaucoup plus de passes de
votants notre objectif c'est qu'on soit
représentatif et pour qu'on le soit il
faut que les les commerçants et et
reçoit descendre la chambre se
mobilisent et qu'ils votent pour que la
chambre les élus qui seront issues de
cette élection soit crédible et reconnu
par les pouvoirs publics cette
anticipation pour vous mais mon objectif
c'est de faire au moins 30%
mais si c'est pas le cas de toute façon
votre élu on serait lui même mais je
trouverais qu'il est dommage que les
ressortissants de la chambre n'est pas
pris conscience de l'intérêt de
l'intérêt de la chambre il ya un travail
à faire sur l'image de la chambre et que
les ressortissants se l'approprient à
nouveau que ce soit un établissement
ouvert ouvert à ses ressortissants et
qui répondent à ses attentes
hier vous étiez au marin le 10e sera
arrêtée hier cette campagne sur le
terrain
elle est indispensable nous essayons de
mobiliser les les ressortissants de la
chambre de telle sorte que comme je vous
le disais la participation soit au moins
30%
le vote se poursuivra jusqu'au 2
novembre merci d'avoir été ce matin avec
nous philippe jacq président président
actuel du medef etc lors dida à la
présidence de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de la martinique